Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in Real
in the one of the final books, second
to last book of Real regarding
various ious narrations,
collections of
stories of history of
stories of various prophets. I mean
the name of the book
remember
is 19 books. It's a collection of 19
books. This 18th book is called
This is the book of the miscellaneous
and
interesting. The miscellaneous and
interesting.
So he starts out the book very strong
with the narrations regarding a dead
jet. and he's got about 10 narrations
that come one right after the other
describing a de we've gone through a
number of them and we're trying to work
through it.
picking up where we left off yesterday,
we or the day before I should say we
discussed the narration of
when they went to
and
they both went to and they asked him to
tell them a narration
regarding a dead
and he told them of the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasallam's description
that one of his descriptions is he has a
river of fire and a river of water. We
remember this narration.
The next narration
we will discuss after the narration of
NS then I guess we did that narration as
well in which the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said there is not a single town,
village or city, no place except that a
dal will enter it except that a dal will
enter it and call its people to believe
in him except for Mecca and Medina. And
then the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us of the three rajat the
three earthquakes that will drive out
all of the hypocrites from Medina.
Annis narrates as well that the
messenger of Allah
[Silence]
And this narrates that the messenger of
Allah
said
of the Yahood.
Now some of the scholars mentioned that
the Yahood here means the Jews,
the Jews residing in Obahan.
Others mention that the Yehood here is
actually a town in Asbahan
and the people from there are referred
to as Yahood. Right? Either way, he will
emerge from Ubahan and Obahan is in
modernday Iran. When he emerges,
he will be followed by 70,000 of the
Yehoud of Albahan.
They will be wearing a toya. A thalisa
is a type of green garment that they
will wear. And what's apparent is this
will be some kind of garb for their
cult. You know, each group that emerges
a lot of times cults and false
prophets and idoltors, they usually have
a certain color or clothing that they
all wear, right? And so these will all
emerge wearing the same clothing, the
same kind of robe, if you will, and
they will emerge following him, 70,000
strong from the land of Asbahan. And
then he will go through Iran, cut
between Iraq to his left and Hashem to
his right, and he will enter into the
Arab Peninsula.
This narration is in Muslim. Another
narration that we mentions also in
Muslim
[Silence]
He says when emerges, people will flee
from him and go hide into the mountains.
Who are these people that will run from
Adel? Obviously, it is the believers.
He is a force
that will move through the earth a
magnet.
a magnet.
He will attract a very certain kind of
person and he will repel
a certain kind of person. You ever take
two magnets and put the positive to the
positive or the negative to the
negative? What happens to the magnets?
They push each other away, right? When
you put a positive to a negative, they
pull each other in. A dead has the exact
same effect.
He will repel the good people and he
will attract the scum. Now, a person may
ask and and we've had this question
before.
Why would Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
allow someone a gel to exist?
Right? If he is such a fitna, why would
he allow someone a deed who wields
that kind of power and influence and
that kind of technology, why would he
allow him to expose himself to the the
the servants of Allah? The answer is
what is the point of this? The point of
this dunya is
that Allah will distinguish and separate
between the good and the bad. This dunya
is a hallway. We're all moving
through it. And there's two doors at the
end. The good end up going through the
right. The people that are bad end up
going to the left. And those who deserve
to be back in paradise are there. And
those who deserve the judgment of Allah
will be receiving it. And so a de will
emerge upon the people in a time when
the world has all become more or less
one culture.
And the Muslim will be few and there
will be a lot of
a lot of interaction to the point
where people the Muslim will have kind
of almost stagnated and then ali will
emerge. He will attract a very
particular type of person. Ael will then
emerge and he will attract in turn a
very particular type of person. And then
he will then descend and he will
judge between them.
Right? And so
he will judge between them based on the
Quran and the Sunnah. He will practice
the legislation of Muhammad sall.ai
wasallam. And so he will descend as as
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
described him.
[Silence]
that
will descend
as a fair and just judge and he will
break the cross and slay the pig, the
swine.
and he will
then the matter of El Jiza will be
put aside and people will either believe
or disbelieve
Muriam. And so we will get to that
narration probably tomorrow night
inshallah that AsaB Miam will be the one
to slay a dead. But do we see the wisdom
of Allah here when we look at it from a
bird's eye view? We see ali comes he
attracts a certain kind of people comes
he attracts a certain kind of people.
Now we have two camps
will then descend and
the great war will occur.
Finally, we have an narration that in
Noah we mentions on the authority of
he and his father are both companions.
[Silence]
Hussein narrates that he heard the
messenger of Allah.
Wasam say from the creation of Adam
until the
until the day of judgment there is no
affair no fitna greater than that of
that will will be upon humanity.
Remember this is you know when you look
at humanity you can look at humanity
as one body.
Imagine what one person goes through the
stages a person goes through in his
life. You go through the very beginning
stage then they learn how to walk.
Adolescence puberty
middleage old age they make their
decisions. They die. Humanity in general
as a whole moves through these stages
and civilizations move through these
stages and nations move through the same
stages that a single person will
naturally move through. And so
and these major fit happening at the end
of humanity
because this is the very final days of
human existence on this earth.
Foreham.
[Silence]
Where did you
all
come?